and we now know the names of most of the
20 people who died eight of the 17 limo
passengers were part of the same family
and the others were all very good
friends a vigil was held for all the
victims last night in Amsterdam New York
that's about 15 miles north of the crash
site
Tony de copal is there Tony good morning
good morning thousands of people packed
into this park last night to remember
the victims at least seven of which were
from this town alone including all four
of those sisters they came to sign the
banner behind me one of the notes on the
banner is from rich and axel steinberg's
mother who wrote there will forever be a
hole in my heart and that's just one
example of how this community is
grieving and reacting to their sudden
loss candle light illuminated a sea of
solemn faces during Monday night's vigil
as his tight-knit New York community
mourned the twenty people killed in
Saturday's limousine crash so much pain
17 of them had gathered for amy
steinberg 30th birthday and were headed
to a brewery in Cooperstown in the
vehicle with Steinberg her husband of
four months her three sisters two of
their husbands and her brother-in-law
also in the group newlyweds Erin and
Shane MacGowan along with Savannah
Mercedes and her boyfriend Matthew Koons
everybody is so close in this area that
everybody knows everybody everywhere
Kurt Smith grew up with many of the
victims including Koons he says they
were like brothers how long do you think
it's going to take this community to be
back to something like normal I think
it'll just be a new normal I don't think
you ever come back from
Amandla house died with her boyfriend
Patrick Cushing Amanda's sister Corina
says her family is broken we're all just
missing that middle piece that Amanda
definitely was she definitely held her
family together she was definitely the
Peacekeeper mary dyson was one of amy
steinberg three sisters killed in the
crash close friend julie robin says
losing dyson and her husband rob is
testing her faith how can God take away
so many people at the same time and
leave kids without parents
adding to the emotion here last night
the knowledge that at least six children
lost one or both of their parents in the
accident now there will be another vigil
tomorrow at the Apple Barrel Country
Store that's where the accident occurred
that will honor the victims their
families and also first responders John
so much pain in one spot in the world
thank you Tony and the more you keep
hearing about the story the more details
you hear the worse it gets we were
saying yes or that and they done the
right thing hiring a truck and hiring a
limo because they want to have a good
time to celebrate a birthday and it ends
up like that he's got breaking GoFundMe
pages were already started for some of
those young children but you're right I
mean so many people to go into a
limousine the first thing they look for
is is not a seat belt right right when I
have fun with their friends exactly
right